wildlife trafficking today is unlike  anything the world has ever seen before  rare animals are being exploited by  criminal syndicates who have access to  advanced technology advanced weapon  systems there's a huge imbalance in  terms of the resources law enforcement  have and the resources criminal networks  have imagine going into the bush against  a group of armed poachers and you're not  sure whether your weapons going to fire  I think the most important and on some  element of wildlife crime are the  Rangers on the ground these men and  women are asked to go out to fight some  of the worst people in the world the  more time I spend doing this the more I  realize this is a human story it is to  the benefit of criminals and their  networks to keep these things in the  dark  so it sounds small but sharing these  stories is incredibly important  you